parler total pierre sabbagh lui a été
entre autres choses je ne me risquerai
pas à résumer même votre carrière merci
vous avez été entre autres choses le
créateur du journal télévisé le journal
télévisé qui lui d'apt de dix ans avant
cinq colonnes à la une
quelle était la date exacte 29 juin 1949
est ce que le 29 juin
ça ne correspond pas à peu de choses
près la saint-pierre exactement et paul
et paul nous livre bien oui je n'avais
pas choisi je vous le dis tout de suite
ça a été l'occasion est l'occasion ça a
été le premier reportage qui a fait du
bruit
moi je peux plus le voir je voulais tout
de suite c'est le reportage en ballon eh
bien nous nous allons le voir peut même
et vous avez moulent comme moi on va
voir ça dans aunès pas forcément il faut
regarder d'information de loin alors non
nous sommes place de la concorde et on
va partir avec audouin dollfus comme
pilote mais je me souviens très bien de
tout ça et il va nous arriver quelques
dagas riga michel bach et beach qui est
à bord et qui tourne bien entendu avec
une une caméra américaine belle intro
relais voilà audouin dollfus lui
survolant paris et je me souviens que
nous sommes passés la très très près du
du paratonnerre l'assemblée nationale
j'ai cru qu'on allait crever dessus non
pas du tout on lâche un peu de lest et
c'est de là que va venir notre malheur
non pas de se laisse qu'on lâche je
souffle pour appeler des gens oui
pourquoi
parce que voilà ce qui se passe nous
lâchons grille d'europe on a vu un arbre
michel michel lasbats la regarde et et
voilà que on va vers l'arbre cet arbre
c'est un pommier et un bravo mac
accroche guy l'europe pour nous retenir
est ce que on va pouvoir atteindre et
arrêter le ballon qui descend qui les
sons dans l'arbre est là nous butons
dedans et là bas à l'horizon que voit-on
on voit une ligne à haute tension unis
haute tension nous butons dans le gaz
s'échappe sans flamme devant les états
celle le ballon brûle qu'un 100 mètres
cubes de gaz qui brûlent voyez j'essaye
d'éteindre j'essaye de sauver ce qui est
sauvable ça s'est bien passé mais pas
avec les gendarmes
mais ça s'est bien passé pour les
championnats nous avons arrêté les
trains dans la région couper le courant
à tout le monde
c'était le début du journal c'est ce que
l'on appelait la clé
brûlant delà tout est-ce que la
télévision croyait au journal télévisé
ou pas du tout paul ou si le directeur
de la radio télévision qui était la
lumière porcher y croyez vraiment à
telle enseigne qu'ils m'avaient demandé
de m'occuper du journal j'avais fait un
projet d'information il est il le
voulait le faire et nous l'avons fait et
d'ailleurs ce qui est très curieux c'est
que les gens de la télévision dont dont
pierre tchernia croyait à ce qu'ils
faisaient
croyez au journal télévisé mais
attention les les augures n'y croyais
pas et alors si vous voulez je voudrais
vous dire et vous allez comprendre que
ce n'est pas dit modestie ce que disait
la presse de ce qu'était le premier
journal télévisé combat en dehors d'un
journal télévisé dont il faudra bien
qu'on sache qu'il est la performance
journalistique la plus sensationnelle de
ce temps le monde
le journal télévisé qui demeure la
meilleure émission de la division
française vient de créer deux nouveaux
magazines
ce matin le pays chaque jour se
renouvellent grâce à 23 hommes
passionnés de leur métier qui travaille
au chronomètre
cette prouesse technique de la presse
française le journal télévisé
les lettres françaises le journal
télévisé c'est l'émission qui maintenant
fait vendre 80% des récepteurs je passe
je vais vous dire pourquoi ce côté
extrêmement laudatif on ne tue pas le
meilleur on n'était pas les plus grands
n'étaient pas admis râble soyons fous
soyons réalistes seulement deux
récepteurs de télévision était pas du
tout ce qu'il est maintenant c'était un
meuble dans la maison et un meuble a
miracle qui vous a porté la vie qui vous
apporter tout ce qui se passe et le
choeur du monde qui battait maintenant
qu'est ce que c'est que le récepteur de
télévision
c'est un membre de la famille on lui dit
tu te tais tu nous donnes ce qu'on veut
c'est pas du tout la même chose le
climat entre les spectateurs et nous
n'est plus du tout le même pied toute
chose et vous pierre tchernia le journal
télévisé quels souvenirs 3 juin et viser
d'abord c'est c'est le souvenir d'une
bande de copains il y avait ce albert il
y avait deux cônes y avait
dumas yay avec hôtel il y avait deux
bluesy on était là on avait tous entre
20 et 30 ans on ne confierait pas
aujourd'hui un journal télévisé que
d'une chose follement importantes à des
mômes de 20 à 30 ans il est vrai qu'il y
avait trois mille cinq cents récepteur
je crois en 1915 nous viendrons chez
vous avez une notion une notion de
bricolage on n'avait pas du tout le
sentiment d' inventer quelque chose on
faisait du bricolage avec des caméras
d'amateurs n'oublions pas que on n'a pas
eu de caméras synchrone c'est à dire on
n'enregistrait pas une image 16 mm de
quelqu'un qui parle on l'a pas eue
pendant trois ou quatre ans cinquante
trois ou quatre jeux 54 et donc qu'on
faisait des images muettes que nous
commentions et je crois que nous avons
inventé sans savoir
c'est un ton nouveau parce que aux
actuels
qu'est ce qu'on connaissait de
l'actualité on connaissait les journaux
d'actualité qui passait dans une salle
de cinéma ou d'un haut parleur tombait
sur 800 ou 1000 spectateurs une voie de
conférence qui disait en présence de
plusieurs personnalités civiles et
militaires s'est déroulée la prise
d'armes dans la cour des invalides
alors que nous nous étions devant un
petit micro il y avait un récepteur
télévision qui nous envoyait l'image et
en direct pour les spectateurs
nous nous mettions à parler en dix ans
les arts ménagers ont commencé ce matin
vous savez ce que c'est une exposition
des voix a ajouté aussi que ça ça nous
permettait l'insolence on disait des
choses épouvantables et pour moi je me
souviens de ce commentaire
entre de caunes et et du mayet qui était
extraordinaire c'était un grand
couturier présentation de mode chez un
grand couturier et tout d'un coup un
blanc et georges qui dit pierre site a
fait un vrai billet comme ça qu'est-ce
qui se passerait je divorce serait que
de suite
voilà le genre de commentaires qu'on se
permet tait c'est impossible maintenant
dans ce fonds devrait plus se le
permettre plus alors voici des extraits
du premier journal télévisé avec les
réactions enregistrées plus tard parce
qu'ils participé à sa création vous
pierre sabbagh michel becquet vite
jacqueline joubert entre autres
on va dire que c'est cette jupe c'est ce
qu'on nous avait donné au début
c'est du militaire qui était
complètement fichue dadis et c'est assez
bon pour eux alors on roulait avec ses 1
avec ça
on ne pouvait pas d'un seul coup d'un
seul m 1 une équipe dans un avion pour
aller au bout du monde
à l'époque ça ce n'est pas du tout on ne
pouvait pas on mangeait le budget d'un
mois c'est bien toujours en train de
courir après l'argent on s'est quand
même inquiet toujours 19 pour en faire
vingt lorsque je demandais des
élastiques on me les donner deux par
deux ont développé à la main ont barboté
à la cantine une boîte de petits pois
vide pour faire les bains et vont se
trouver à un certain moment ne pas avoir
les moyens d'acheter entre autres la
soude caustique
c'est alors que dans le cadre des
dépenses dites en menus dépenses j'ai
pensé à aller acheter du débouché
juillet et on faisait les révélateurs
pendant quelques jours on a développé
les films avec du débouché ce journal
comporter un reportage réalisé par andré
michel sur la kermesse aux étoiles qui
avait été tourné donc le dimanche
précédant le 26 je crois que c'est fait
de la 2e db c'est ça la fête de la
deuxième d'aisé nous avions
essentiellement de reportages
d'information générale peu de sport il y
avait des
sujet que l'on abordait pratiquement
jamais c'était les sujets politiques
on a inventé des personnages et je crois
c'est tchernia soit pierre tchernia qui
a inventé schwarzenberg
alors monsieur schwarzenberg a love song
était un basketteur c'était un homme
politique autrichien
c'était un nageur c'était le créateur
d'une botte folk on avait trouvé on sait
pas d'où elle venait
c'était tout ça je vois l'irak après ça
on en a eu beaucoup d'autres
on a eu tous les soldats us albertson ça
bastonne charles dutton du maillage
joueur avait écrit son texte sur un
ticket de métro et quelques temps avant
il avait dû s'acheter une voiture il
n'avait plus de tickets de métro alors
il à laisser défiler le sujet et à la
fin il a dit bas - yeux